hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 14 video
lots of Captain America Civil War stuff
brewing in the background so I'll try to
explain how they're integrating that
into the story along with the Inhumans
stuff it's funny how the TV shows are
laying the groundwork for movies that
are years away Captain America Civil War
is coming out next year so it's not that
far away but it makes sense that they
use the TV audience to create awareness
for big stuff that's gonna be happening
later on so just careful for spoilers
from the episode if you haven't seen it
yet starting with top five moments
number five Pulp Fiction intro if you
didn't recognize it they use the exact
same diner that they used on the show
last week the tone of that opening scene
between Ward and agent 33 is almost
exactly the same as the opening scene
from Pulp Fiction where they start with
the diner heist funny because Tim Roth
who was in that opening scene played
abomination in the Incredible Hulk and
agent 33 kind of thinks of herself as an
abomination very meta Marvel verse type
stuff I totally love it when it gets
referential like this and I'm totally
digging the creepy sexual stuff that's
going on between agent 33 and ward very
clearly that's gonna turn into some kind
of ship whether or not at last I don't
know I think it depends on how stable
agent 33 stays clearly like she's still
recovering from what happened to her
she's imprinted on Ward but I think he's
manipulating her just like people
manipulated Ward ever since he showed
his true colors whenever he's really
earnest like this when he's just seems
too nice it's way too good to be true
he's definitely lying through his teeth
I do think that he's gonna keep his
promise to Skye he's gonna reunite her
with her father and her family this
other Inhumans group but the real
question is is what else is he trying to
do that can't be his only goal I know a
lot of people are wondering if he's
turning into like taskmaster from the
comics I don't think that's the case I
think he's gonna be his own thing he's
an original creation of the show he's
just a villainous character that
operates outside of the boundaries of
major organization so he's not like
completely Hydra not completely shield
not even really much of an antihero I
still think of him as a villain like a
free agent equal-opportunity villain
seriously though we have to talk about
that Skye lingerie scene that was so
creepy and so much fun I am so happy
when agents of shield can make my skin
crawl like that I feel like a lot of the
fun on the show a lot of the humor is
gonna be born out of this crazy Ward
storyline and when I say humor I mean
really dark humor which is
one of the best kinds haunts number four
the real shield explained edward james
olmos his character gonzalez isn't
straight out of the comics but he is
totally setting up civil war like all
this secret shield versus real shield
stuff is setting up what's gonna be
going on in civil war who is accountable
to who transparency versus operating in
the shadows that's like the big
difference of opinion in the comics
civil wars is very very different it's
all about superhero registration Captain
America doesn't think the superheroes
need to show their faces Iron Man says
they need to it's way more complicated
than that that's like an
oversimplification but the impetus for
Captain America and Iron Man drawing a
line in the sand is gonna be different
in the movies than it is in the comics
they kind of explain this a little bit
when they did the Marvel phase three
announcement where they introduced
chadwick boseman is black panther I
might do some more Civil War comic book
videos in the future but because the TV
show and the movies are gonna do
something different I'm mostly gonna
focus on that stuff Edward James almost
is gonna be a lot of fun though this
season
I love seeing Adama again especially in
a really like contentious position of
authority like this a secret
organization inside of a secret
organization just to explain what Mac
and Bobby have been doing for real
shield while they're inside of Coulson
shield they're looking for the toolbox
and they're gonna be trying to find out
where Skye is I also thought it was
funny that all those people including
hunter still think that Nick Fury is
dead I don't think they were lying I've
said it a couple times before but I
think at a certain point in the movies
we will see Secret Avengers I think it
won't be till we get to Civil War but
eventually we'll get there there'll be
two different teams of Avengers although
technically the Avengers will break up
and it'll be two teams of superheroes I
don't know if either one is gonna call
themselves the Avengers on to number
three Skye goes to Inhumans summer camp
totally love the way Fitz and Simmons
were arguing about which Avenger Skye
was most like Captain America or the
Hulk technically I think Simmons is more
right because she can't really control
her powers right now but they asked a
really important question if Bruce
Banner could get rid of his powers
should he be allowed to because he does
do a lot of good as the Hulk the problem
with that is that none of those
characters have read the Illuminati
that's the storyline where Marvel's
Illuminati group Reed Richards Iron Man
Doctor Strange all the other Illuminati
including Black Bolt shoot Hulk into
space because he becomes such a problem
that they
deal with obviously they're not gonna be
shooting sky into space anytime soon but
but I think it's kind of funny because
he has you know
Hulk is good he is an Avenger but he
also causes as much damage as he
prevents so it's kind of a wash in the
comics though Daisy Johnson the
characters that Skye is on the show she
does join The Avengers eventually her
upgraded gauntlets look pretty cool it
looks like they're full-on gloves I
think Coulson called them gloves if
gaining mutant powers is a metaphor for
people becoming sexually active I mean
that's originally what it was in the
comics then think of these gloves is a
chastity belt or birth control I guess
if it were a chastity belt they would
completely block her powers make as many
condoms Oaks as you want but but
basically what she's gonna be doing at
this cabin is just playing with her
powers I think it's gonna take her the
rest of the season to figure her powers
out until we get to a gloves off kind of
moment metaphorically and literally
she'll take the gloves off and be like
crazy powerful dudes like something
crazy big it just feels like a really
easy spectacle that they could put in
the finale like it's all about you know
humor Hart spectacle and the spectacle
part being the big superpower stuff on
to number two 33 and ward are
brainwashing Bakshi this is so much fun
you know a nice twist on the Whitehall
scenes what they're probably gonna do is
try and brainwash him replant him inside
Hydra and use him to run counter
operations against them or they could
still program him and replant him back
inside the US government if you remember
in the mid-season premiere all the heads
of Hydra said that Bakshi was the next
best candidate to become a new head of
Hydra to replace Whitehall so it's
possible that that could still happen
and speaking of Whitehall this is really
important because I feel like he is the
one common villain amongst all the
different groups on the show doesn't it
just feel like they're laying seeds for
him to become the overarching villain
for the Inhumans as well as real shield
Coulson shield and agent 33 in Ward like
that a little Splinter Cell it's like
despite all their differences of opinion
everyone agrees Whitehall is awful so
just open up a tab in chrome for
Whitehall big bad return and finally my
number one WTF moment Coulson and may
totally knows something is going on with
Mack and hunter whenever there's a
character on screen lying to Coulson or
May I always get the feeling that they
secretly know they're being lied to
it just feels like in the past in the
Avengers movies as well as in agents of
shield season 1 clothes on
voice knows when he's being lied to he
might not know exactly what's going on
but he knows when you're not telling the
truth
that's just more fuel on the civil war
fire the real question we need to ask
and actually here here's my big question
for you guys you can just answer in the
comments do you think that you know once
all the secrets come out about real
shield that Coulson's team will reunite
by the season finale the other
possibility is is that it could split
him down the middle so that during
season 3 you have a lot more shield in
fighting they're totally gonna do a
Captain America Civil War shield
crossover just like they did in Captain
America Winter Soldier and just like
they're gonna do an age of Ultron
they're always gonna have minor
crossovers between the films and the TV
shows I do think that real shield vs.
shield will continue to be a thing in
season 3 it just feels like it works too
well within the context of Captain
America's Civil War for them to get rid
of it right away in related news
daredevil is getting ready to premiere
on Netflix so if you guys don't have
Netflix make sure you get it it's gonna
be an amazing TV series I'm not
expecting it to crossover with agents of
shield or the movies a whole lot maybe
in season two I think they just want to
start it as its own thing first just to
see how it does and they're also setting
up Jessica Jones and all these other
Netflix series so it's largely going to
be self-contained to these other shows
that are on Netflix be sure to subscribe
to get all my videos what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna start doing more daredevil
bonus videos as we get closer to that
it's really only a couple of weeks away
it's gonna be a lot of fun make sure you
guys check it out I know everyone's
wondering if I'm gonna do like videos
for every single episode or if I'm just
gonna do a couple videos but I'll
probably do is I'll just do like one
video for every two or three episodes
and just post one every like three or
four days there's just like no way I can
make like 13 different videos in two
days it's also the same weekend the Game
of Thrones premiers daredevil drops the
Friday before Game of Thrones Season 5
episode 1 air so it is gonna be such an
amazing weekend I probably won't sleep
but it'll be a lot of fun well you guys
wait for that you can click here to
learn all about the Captain America
Civil War director's taking over the
Avengers franchise for Joss Whedon it's
gonna be really exciting and you can
click here for all my other agents of
shield videos thank you so much for
watching now let's all high five I'll
see you guys again tonight
you